اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي مقتل ثلاثه عسكريين
في معارك شماليه قطاع غزه
وجنوبه احدهم ضابط كما اشار الى اصابه
خمسه اخرين جروح بعضهم خطيره وبهذا يبلغ
عدد القتلى العسكريين 560 على الاقل منذ
عمليه طوفان الاقصى في السابع من اكتوبر
الماضي ومن بين هؤلاء 230 ضابطا وجنديا
قتلوا منذ بدء العمليه البريه وقتل 54
منهم منذ مطلع العام الحالي وكان الجيش قد
اعلن ان 26 جنديا وضابطا نقلوا من غزه الى
المستشفيات في اسرائيل بعد اصابتهم في
معارك شمال وجنوب قطاع غزه خلال ال 24
ساعه الماضيه واضاف ان هذه المعارك تركزت
بشكل خاص في خانيونس والضواحي الشرقيه
لمدينه
غزه معنا من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره
وليد العمري اذا وليد لا يزال الجيش يسري
تفاصيل عن عدد خسائره في صفوف القوات
المقاتله سواء من الضباط او من الجنود ما
الذي يدفعه الى الحديث بكل هذه
التفاصيل يدفعه الى ذلك لان لديه خسائر
وهو ملزم بان يعلن ذلك على الراي العام
بعد ان يكون قد ابلغ ذويهم بوقوع هذه
الخسائر لكن اللافت في كل هذا الامر ان
بيانه هذا اليوم الليله يتحدث عن وقوع
قتلى في شمالي قطاع غزه وهي المنطقه التي
قال انه خفف من وجود قواته فيها واخرجها
من المناطق الماهوله او التي كانت ماهوله
ودمرها وقتل الكثيرين من سكانها في اشاره
الى ان المعارك سواء في منطقه تل الهواء
او مخيم الشاطئ في منطقه غرب منطقه مدينه
غزه وكذلك في منطقه شمال شرق جباليا ما
تزال متواصله و هناك انقضاض من قبل خلايا
مسلحه من المقاومه الفلسطينيه التي تقوم
بمهاجمه قواته او كما يسمونها بتطور حرب
العصبات في هذه المنطقه اما المنطقه التي
تشهد القتال الضاري بالفعل فهي منطقه خان
يونس في هذه المنطقه في جنوبي القطاع
والتي يعتبرها عاصمه المقاومه وتحديدا
عاصمه كتائب القسام كان قد قسم هو ال قطاع
غزه قبل اكثر من شهر الى نحو
62 مربعا
قال للسيطره عليها من بينها عدد كبير في
منطقه خانيونس والجنوب ويعمل منذ ايام على
طريقه الاستهداف المركز بحيث يستهدف مربعا
تلو اخر سواء بالقصف من الجو والمدفعيه او
بالدفع في دبابات ولكن الاهم وجود قوات
كوماندوز من وحدات النخبه سواء شداك في
سلاح الجو او شيات 13 في سلاح البحريه
وكذلك من سياره متكال وهي نخبه النخبه في
الجيش
الاسرائيلي المواقع التي تجري فيها القتال
وفق بياناته ويقول انه اوقع خسائر فادحه
بالمقاومه وقتل اكثر من 100 خلال الليله
الماضيه وعثر على مخازن اسلحه ودمر منصات
اطلاق صواريخ كانت جاهزه للاطلاق ومن
بينها المنصه التي اطلقت منها صواريخ امس
الاول على منطقه تل ابيب الكبرى يقول انه
يحقق تقدما بطيئا فوق الارض وتحت الارض
لكنه سيواصل قتاله هذا كله ياتي وسط حاله
من الغموض حول الهدف الاستراتيجي ما اذا
ستشمل هذه المعارك ايضا وتمتد الى منطقه
رفح ومنطقه محور فيلادلفيا الفاصل بين
قطاع غزه وبين سناء المصريه وهي مساله
تخضع لامور واعتبارات السياسيه لكن الواضح
بان هذه المعارك متواصله لليوم ال 117 في
كافه ارجاء قطاع غزه واطلاق الصواريخ امس
الاول من منطقه خان يونس تحديدا في الجنوب
فيما قوات الجيش الاسرائيلي تجتاح مناطق
كثيره وطائراته الاستكشافيه تعمل وتقصف
كان اهميتها في مجرد اطلاقها بنظر الخبراء
لانه ان تتمكن كتائب القسام من اطلاق هذه
الصواريخ وسط هذه الحاله الحربيه ونحو
مناطق بعيده نحن نتحدث عن منطقه تل ابيب
الكبرى تل ابيب من حدود الشماليه لقطاع
غزه 62 م لكن من منطقه خانيونس قد يصل ذلك
الى 90 م واكثر بمعنى انها صواريخ بعيده
المدى الى منطقه تل ابيب تحديدا هذا كان
المؤشر عليه بان هذه المقاومه ما زالت
قادره على اداره المعارك واداره الشؤون
الاخرى المتعلقه بهذه المعارك شكرا جزيلا
لك من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد
العمري